j'ai voulu vous réunir
je les fais en tant que premier ministre
c'est à dire dans l'esprit de la
constitution de la vème république
en tant que chef de la majorité mais je
les fais aussi comme principal
responsable de l'ud dr groupe le plus
important et le plus nombreux de cette
majorité
et c'est parce que je suis premier
ministre que j'assume des
responsabilités dans l'ue des airs et
notamment celle de coordonner l'action
de l'ue des airs avec celles des autres
mouvements de la majorité et je compte
sur chaque député sur chaque élu pour
que chiffres en main il démontre aux
français que pour nous les promesses
électorales ne s'évanouissent pas au
lendemain des élections
nous ne laisserons pas détruire la vème
république par des brûlots en france le
pouvoir ne vient pas ne peut pas venir
de luttes menées en sous-main est
alimentée par de petites phrases
la france est et doit demeurer un pays
de liberté où l'on ne triche pas avec
les règles de la démocratie
à ceux qui ont procédé à des amalgames
hâtif sur les événements tragiques qui
endeuille le chili faut-il rappeler que
les situations n'ont rien de comparable
en particulier nos armées de se préparer
à défendre la patrie s'il le fallait et
c'est le faire injure que de laisser
croire qu'elle pourrait cesser de
respecter ou de faire respecter la loi
quant à la prévention des coups de force
la vème république n'a à recevoir de
leçons de personne en ce domaine
puisqu'elle a été capable de ruiner
il y acquiert plus de dix ans celui qui
avait été au rugby pour la battre nous
acceptons le seul combat qui soit
démocratique celui des idées et des
propositions avec les élections pour
sanction mais le gouvernement ne se
laissera pas intimider par aucune menace
et il réprima s'il le faut le désordre
et l'agitation